So before we go any further, I want to have a real quick recap of Unreal Engine 5 just
to interface, movement, and what actors are just so that we're all familiar with different
terms and things like that.
So let's go ahead and just take a look at the user interface.
So across the top here, we have our file menu.
So this is going to be the same file menu that we see throughout the editor.
We're going to access things like editing new levels or creating new levels for us to
edit from up there.
We're going to look at things like documentation reference, project settings, editor settings,
and things like that.
Now two is going to be our main toolbar.
This is we're going to be creating new types of content or actors to add to our levels.
We can also adjust our tool set to further refine the types of tools that we're using
here in the selection mode.
We have the ability to play and then adjust for our platform that we want to quickly launch
on as well as some settings to deal with rendering.
So three is going to be our level of viewport.
This is where we're going to spend most of our time editing things and adding things
and moving them around as well as adjusting our lighting and things like that.
So for here, this is our tabbed drawer system.
These menu options can be moved around and things like that.
The Outliner allows us to look at things that are placed in the level and the Details panel
allows us to get more information about anything that we click on.
So the Details panel is context sensitive, meaning that when we click on it, different
things are going to show us different items in the Details panel.
Five is our content drawer.
This is where we can access the content browser.
And then six, this is going to be where we access our output log or enter any console
commands.
And this is particularly important if we're doing any type of a debug information or anything
like that.
So next on our list, we have viewport navigation.
So remember, you can view navigate the viewport in Unreal two different ways.
You can use the WASND key along with the QE to move the camera up and down with Q and
E or holding down the right mouse button.
You can use WASND to move the camera forward, backwards, left and right.
You can also navigate through Unreal using just the mouse by holding down the left mouse
button.
You can move the mouse forward, backwards, and turn left and right.
But holding down the right mouse button, you can drag the static POV around the scene.
And by holding down the middle mouse button, you could actually track the camera.
A couple of other things that are important, F to focus in on an object makes it extremely
useful.
Should you lose that object or you maybe get thrown out of the scene really far away and
you need to get your way back in, F can be a great way to focus in on stuff.
You can also use ALT and the left mouse button to drag and orbit or tumble around the object.
And then ALT right mouse button will drag and dolly the camera further away from you.
Alright, so working with actors.
So actors again are objects that can be placed or spawned into a level.
And we're going to be working with a bunch of different actors.
So it's important to know what they are.
And here's actually just a collection of actors and basically the stuff that we are
going to be working with.
So that's it.
That wraps up our Unreal Engine recap.
We will see you in our next section.